[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est un sens public
entièrement consacré aux violences
urbaines de ces derniers jours que je
vous propose ce soir c'est violent et
les réponses que le gouvernement est
l'ensemble de la classe politique
peuvent te apporter car un cran
supplémentaire a été franchi dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche quand le
domicile du maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses a
été visé par une attaque incendiaire à
la voiture bélier des rassemblements de
soutien ont lieu dans toutes les mairies
de France aujourd'hui et aussi dans
cette ville du Val-de-Marne pour dire ça
suffit
chers citoyens de France nous relevons
la tête nous faisons face sans détourner
le regard nous reprenons la parole pour
que la majorité jusqu'ici l'ancieuse
puisse se faire entendre et dire STOP ça
suffit
150 mairies ou bâtiments municipaux
visés depuis mardi dernier pourquoi
sont-ils ciblés par les émeutiers
comment reconstruire une démocratie
apaisée ce sera notre premier débat et
puis juste après on cherchera à
comprendre qui sont ceux qui brûlent et
qui pillent selon le ministre de
l'intérieur ils sont jeunes parfois très
jeunes
sur les 2000 interpellations que nous
avons faites qui ont vraiment un montant
très important d'interpellation montrant
ainsi la fermeté de l'État je veux dire
que l'âge moyen c'est 17 ans des
personnes qu'on a interpellé nous avons
interpellé des incendies qui avaient
12-13 ans
la démission de certains parents le rôle
de l'école la question des sanctions
judiciaires et plus généralement la
défiance pour ne pas dire la haine entre
certains jeunes et la police ont
analysera toutes ces questions dans
trois quarts d'heure mais d'abord on
rejoint Audrey vutaz et Cécile six sous
dans le Val-de-Marne ou plusieurs
personnalités politiques sont devenues
soutenir le maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses
Audrey comment s'est passé s'est
déroulée cette marche républicaine
et bien comme un symbole la marche a
démarré ici de la mairie barricadé de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses barricadé avec des fils
barbelés en tête de cortège Vincent Jean
Brun le maire entouré de Gérard Larcher
le président du Sénat de Valérie
Pécresse la Présidente de la Région
Île-de-France ou encore d'Éric Ciotti le
président des républicains mais il y
avait aussi de très nombreuses élus
venus soutenir le maire écoutez
semblait important que toute les forces
politiques puissent être présents ici
pour montrer que ce n'est pas un objet
de polémique et puis j'ai envie de dire
qu'il y a une gauche qui est intraitable
avec les violences qui ne les encourage
pas et je pense que ma présence ici
témoigne aussi de la réalité de cette
gauche qui ne trouve pas de
circonstances atténuantes aux attaques
contre la République aux attaques contre
les équipements et surtout aux attaques
contre les personnes je crois
qu'aujourd'hui les les
figures d'autorité toutes les figures
d'autorité sont attaquées parce qu'elles
sont figures d'autorité donc la question
c'est la rétablissement de l'autorité
dans ce pays et le respect de l'autorité
dans ce pays un parcours sous les
applaudissements à de très nombreuses
reprises on a aussi entendu la
Marseillaise il y a eu aussi des cris ça
suffit qui ont été prononcés je vous
propose d'écouter une habitante de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses elle travaille avec un
public très jeune elle est allée dire
quelques mots au maire on l'a senti très
ému écoutez
tu investis depuis des années dans la
vie associative auprès des enfants
faisant de la pédagogie et puis là j'ai
l'impression que tout ce qu'on fait
s'effondre auprès des jeunes donc voilà
mais en tous les cas on espère remonter
la pente et refaire revivre notre ville
de L'Haÿ-les-Roses la marche se
terminait par une prise de parole du
maire et à la question d'un journaliste
pourquoi avez-vous été ciblés voici ce
qu'il a répondu celles et ceux qui ont
cassé pendant des jours celles et ceux
qui ont attaqué la mairie celles et ceux
qui ont été jusqu'à attaquer ma maison
je crois pas qu'ils aient attaqué
Vincent Jean Brun je crois pas qu'ils
aient attaqué ma personne c'est le
symbole qu'ils ont attaqué on l'a vu
pendant ces journées on l'a vu partout
en France on l'a vu par les autres mères
qui ont été agressés parce qu'encore une
fois on n'est pas les seuls c'est bien
là tout le drame c'est parce que ces
personnes ne se reconnaissent plus dans
la République
le maire qui a conclu par un message
d'espoir les émetiers n'étaient que 200
nous sommes plus nombreux il faut se
remonter les manches mais déjà dans
l'assemblée certains appellent à des
sanctions très claires très nettes
envers ceux qui s'attaquent à des élus
avec des peines de prison ferme voilà
cette question merci beaucoup Audrey
merci également à Cécile six sous cette
question des des sanctions évidemment ce
sera l'un des thèmes de notre débat avec
Jérôme Guibert bonsoir bien sûr vous
êtes président de la Fabrique écologique
ancienne élu de l'agglomération du Mans
vous avez été adjoint au maire également
vice-président de la Communauté Urbaine
du Mans et vous publiez ce livre le
grand malentendu climatique aux Éditions
de l'Aube j'accueille également
Jean-Sébastien Ferjou bonsoir
Jean-Sébastien vous êtes fondateur
directeur d'Atlantico Florent Vaillot
bonsoir bienvenue c'est le président de
l'étheri cercle de réflexion qui a pour
objet de produire et diffuser une
réflexion de gauche sur les sujets qui
structure la vie politique française et
vous êtes enseignant à Sciences Po on a
également deux invités qui sont avec
nous en duplex Françoise Gatel la
présidente de la délégation sénatoriale
aux collectivités territoriales et à la
décentralisation vous êtes sénatrice
centriste d'Ille-et-Vilaine bonsoir à
vous et co-auteur de la proposition de
loi renforçant la sécurité des élus
locaux et la protection des mers qui a
été déposé au Sénat c'était en mai le
mois dernier on mai dernier il y a le
moins puis on duplexe également Arnaud
bazinc et sénateur LR du Val d'Oise et
ancien maire de Persan dans les années
95-2011 merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation Mathieu croissanto évidemment
est à mes côtés comme chaque lundi et
mercredi politique je vous propose pour
ouvrir ce débat de d'entendre de nouveau
le maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses Vincent Jean
Brun raconté ce qui s'est passé dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche j'ai presque
le plus choquant c'est que c'est pas que
la maison qu'ils ont attaqué puisque en
fait à partir du moment où la lumière
s'allume à l'intérieur de la maison
puisque ma femme est réveillée il
continue il continue à essayer de
ramener le feu jusqu'à la maison en
prenant les conteneurs de poubelles qui
se trouve en faisant un espèce de chemin
de conteneur de poubelle jusqu'à la
véranda en prenant un olivier en pot
qui était ouvert elle collé à la véranda
tout ça pour pour vraiment que le feu de
la voiture aille jusqu'à la maison alors
qu'il voit qu'il y a de la lumière à
l'intérieur et même avec la lumière il
commence à faire des tirs de mortier en
direction en direction de la maison des
tirs de mortier qui sortent un passeront
d'ailleurs au-dessus de la maison et
donnera l'impression à ma femme qui à ce
moment-là à bille enfin mets des
chaussures aux enfants en leur disant
s'enfu on s'enfuit cours dans le jardin
donc il faut imaginer la scène de le
noir total avec juste une espèce de
lumière rouge immense qui qui est à
l'avant de la maison puisque les
agresseurs avaient des espèces de fusée
de détresse
et donc c'est ce que mon fils m'a appelé
dix fois il y a cette lumière rouge
c'est tout rouge peut passer tout rouge
voilà pour ce témoignage je tenais à ce
qu'on ouvre ce débat en le réécoutant
parce que j'imagine que les uns les
autres vous l'aviez déjà entendu
jérogibert quel mot vous employez pour
caractériser ce qui s'est passé ce soir
là j'utilise le mot de scandale de honte
c'est pas la première fois qu'on
s'attaque à des élus il y a eu
Saint-Brevin il y a eu d'autres cas mais
là c'est un cas particulièrement
scandaleux et emblématique puisque c'est
la taxe sur la vie privée en plus et je
pense qu'il y a vraiment deux choses qui
sont attaquées dans cette affaire et en
effet la République et la démocratie
puisque ce sont des élus et les élus
c'est nous qui les élisons et donc c'est
bien la démocratie qu'on essaye de
contester en les attaquant et en faisant
pression sur eux et c'est pas la
première fois moi-même j'ai été élu et
j'ai bien vu la montée progressive des
insultes des etc appartenant ou on ne
répond pas à la demande des concitoyens
ou à la demande individuelle de tel ou
telle citoyen en particulier et la
deuxième chose très importante qui est
attaquée c'est le bien commun
parce que qu'est-ce que fait un élu
local qu'est-ce que fait un maire
concrètement un maire il arbitre un
certain nombre d'intérêts particuliers
sur l'urbanisme sur les choix en matière
de d'investissement sur y compris la
réponse sur les logements sur les
emplois il arbitre entre un certain
nombre d'intérêts particuliers et donc
il essaye de définir d'une certaine
façon l'intérêt général de la Commune et
c'est un travail essentiel pour une
société qui veut faire sens et c'est là
où je pense qu'il y a cette attaque sur
le bien commun et tout aussi gravissime
et particulièrement gravissime elle
aussi Jean-Sébastien Ferjoux il y a 5
semaines c'était en conseil des
ministres le prennent la République
parlait de d'un processus de
décibilisation est-ce que vous employez
ce terme ou pas
je sais pas si c'est le plus intéressant
en l'espèce en ce qui concerne Vincent
Vincent Jean Brun moi je vois quand même
une dimension profondément politique il
y a toute la dimension symbolique que
vous venez d'écrire j'espère que
l'enquête permettra d'établir de faire
la lumière vraiment sur les faits parce
que vous l'évoquez un maire est aussi là
pour arbitrer entre des intérêts
particuliers et il peut y avoir des
violences d'opportunisme parce que c'est
ça aussi il peut y avoir des
spécificités peut-être à la commune de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses et avec Vincent Jean
Brun qui aurait dérangé X ou x intérêt
particulier ce qui me justifie
évidemment pas que on s'entraîne ni à
lui ni à son domicile ni à sa famille
moi ce qui me fera plus justement dans
cette dimension politique là parce que
je crois qu'il faut bien distinguer ce
qu'on a pu voir justement des images
d'émeutes plus spontanées diront avec
toutes les vidéos qu'on a pu voir sur
snapchat etc et une dimension plus
structurée quand même alors je voyais
que par exemple certains titres de la
presse marocaine disait ce que l'Algérie
est en train de jeter de l'huile sur le
feu on sait que l'Algérie a les moyens
d'activer certains de ces réseaux c'est
une question en l'état est-ce que
l'extrême gauche et aussi impliqué
justement dans la partie non spontanée
des émeutes quoi qu'il en soit vous
poser des questions vous avez pas les
réponses à ces questions non parce que
mais j'espère qu'il faut enfin que ça ne
sera pas comme d'habitude on met la
poussière sous le tapis parce qu'une
fois que le câble est revenu surtout
avec les vacances on passe à autre chose
qu'on aura le courage d'aller au bout et
moi ce que je ne comprends pas c'est la
tolérance alors on entendait dans le
reportage François calfond qui parlait
de la gauche qui n'accepte pas les
violences en creux on entend bien qu'il
y en a donc une qui non seulement des
acceptes mais les entretiens et moi j'en
en parlera un peu plus tard mais oui
mais je trouve que c'est un point parce
que la question de l'extrême gauche vous
avez vu dès le début de la marche
blanche il y avait à sa Traoré à sa
Traoré c'est un certain de de groupe des
coloniaux indigénistes etc qui sont
présents ce n'est pas que de l'émotion
et ça n'est pas que de la dénonciation
de de d'injustice ou de cette tragédie
là en particulier il y a une dimension
politique ne l'ignorons pas alors est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ça alors on
va dire est-ce qu'il y a une dimension
politique parce que forcément on fait le
on compare avec Saint-Brevin l'attaque
contrôle domicile du maire qui avait été
un peu moins violente mais enfin quand
même et qui avait poussé à sa démission
et là c'était des mouvements d'extrême
droite à la suite de l'accepte
l'acceptation par le maire de
Saint-Brévin de déplacer un centre
d'accueil des des demandeurs d'asile
près d'une école bon est-ce que vous
faites le parallèle est-ce que vous
dites sont deux cas très différents
dimensions politiques ou pas moi
j'attends de voir le résultat de
l'enquête pour voir effectivement s'il y
avait dans les dans les acteurs de cette
incendie et tentative d'assassinat un
motif politique ce que j'observe
néanmoins c'est que en l'état de nos
informations il y a quand même une
différence majeure entre Saint-Brevin et
L'Haÿ-les-Roses c'est que
Saint-Brevin le but était un but
politique pour infléchir une décision
politique là on laisse et il y a pas eu
de doute sur le fait que on savait
pourquoi c'était en l'espèce sur
L'Haÿ-les-Roses on n'a pas de
revendication on ne sait pas quelle est
la volonté si ce n'est cette extase
toucher et cette volonté d'atteindre la
République et d'atteindre ce qui est
considéré comme l'autorité le pouvoir de
l'État en mettant un distinctement les
élus locaux et l'État donc moi je mets
je ne mettrai pas pour l'instant une
intention politique au sens de politique
structuré avec une intention d'infléchir
une politique pour l'instant rien un
indique cela est aux demandes quelque
chose de plus politique encore mettre à
bas les institutions et la République
quand Jean-Luc Mélenchon dit hier soir
ça n'est pas la police c'est la police
des riches c'est riche qui se sont
sauvagés leur police quand la directrice
de l'Institut La Boétie d'un site le
sint-angle de la France insoumise dit je
vous rappelle que la République a été
fondée par des émeutiers détruisant un
bâtiment public donc à savoir la
Bastille qu'elle explique ensuite que
Emmanuel Macron est un tyran et que les
institutions de la Cinquième République
sont iraniques pardon ça évoque quand
même furieusement le fameux article de
la Constitution 1793 sur le droit à
l'insurrection donc ça il me semble que
pour le coup c'est politique et la
différence avec Saint-Brevin c'est que
alors oui je crois qu'il ne faut pas
estimé les dangers d'extrême droite on
l'a vu encore vous avez joué avec les
manifestations qui ont pu avoir lieu à
Angers pendant les émeutes mais la
différence c'est que personne dans le
champ politique par personne n'a soutenu
et accompagné
et ensuite je donne la parole à nous
d'abord pour l'instant je lui Mélenchon
et pas inquiété pour
l'incendie de la maison de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses et je pense qu'il faut
éviter de vouloir faire un continuum de
violence entre des émeutiers et une
gauche politique qui effectivement
pour l'instant c'est vous sur ce plateau
et je vais quand même finir une phrase
on va aller on va non non la France
insoumise la fête elle-même c'est pas
moi Sébastien va laisser Florent en tout
cas je n'ai pas entendu je vais pas
mettre à défendre la France insoumise
mais je n'ai pas entendu dans la France
insoumise des appels à la violence qui
consistait à incendie les les domiciles
des mers il y a un contexte
d'instrumentalisation
des violence sociale et la convergence
élu qui a été théorisée donc on va pas
le nier et pour l'instant je n'ai pas vu
cette volonté si vous voulez bien on y
reviendra sur cette question là on
écoutera même le
la réaction de Jean-Luc Mélenchon dont
vous parliez ou donner en quelque sorte
on peut l'interpréter comme ça une liste
de ce qu'il fallait sauvegarder mais je
voudrais quand même une première fois et
en restant centré sur ce qui s'est passé
à L'Haÿ-les-Roses en temps de Françoise
Gatel qu'est-ce que là aussi je pose un
peu la même question quel mot vous
mettez je pense que quand vous avez je
dis tout à noter les spectateurs
préparer l'émission avec avec l'équipe
de sciences publiques vous parliez d'une
société décérébrée pourquoi vous
dites-vous ça
parce que bonjour d'abord je voudrais
dire toute mon amitié tout mon soutien à
tous les élus et particulièrement aux
mains de l'aile rose je pense que chacun
cherche un sens ou des raisons à ce qui
se passe et je crois qu'il n'y en a pas
puisque je pense que tous ces auteurs
d'agression de violence de tentatives
d'assassinat ne peuvent pas raisonner
comme nos raisonnons les uns et les
autres c'est comme s'ils étaient des
cérébrés et ce mot m'est venu quand j'ai
entendu un jeune qui était interviewé
qui avait un moment rejoint des groupes
dans lequel il y avait des actions
peut-être de se nature au moins qui a
dit tout simplement quand on est en gros
on perd notre cerveau c'est à dire on
est dans une folie absolue dont je ne
sais pas quel est la part d'influence de
Mélenchon ou pas je pense qu'il y en a
une mais est-ce que ces jeunes ils
entendent ils écoutent je ne sais pas
moi je vous dis tout simplement que les
causes sont sans doute multifactoriels
et qu'en tout cas que fait-on
aujourd'hui et demain pour prévenir et
que pour faire que aucun je n'ira cramé
une maison dans laquelle il y a des
enfants il y a une femme et avec cette
volonté délibérée
d'attenter à la vie de gens moi je ne
vois pas le chemin de la raison dans
tout ça sauf à dire que voilà on est à
un moment la société elle est décérébrée
elle n'est plus elle est totalement
déconstruite sauf que je pense qu'il y a
des jeunes qui un moment n'ont jamais eu
de construction et de raison parce que
ils sont dans un univers qui est
totalement irréel c'est à dire est-ce
que ils ont l'impression de participer à
une compète de jeux vidéo moi ces images
me faisait penser au film Orange
mécanique que certains d'entre nous ont
dû voir où il y a une violence poussée à
l'extrême et ça ça nous ramène quelques
décennies en arrière je voudrais
entendre une première fois Arnaud Bazin
sur peut-être est-ce que vous est-ce que
vous vous mettez ce matin à la place du
maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses d'abord centré
sur ce ce qui s'est passé ensuite on
pourra élargir un petit peu mais comment
revenir à son poste d'une certaine façon
comment comment ne pas être solidaire
comment ne pas être en empathie totale
avec le maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses quand
on a été soi-même pendant 16 ans le
maire d'une commune populaire et avec
beaucoup de bonheur
une étape a été franchise a été dit une
de plus dans une dans une escalade
interminable dans ma commune
malheureusement nous avons une
redoutable expérience de
de son connu 2005 nous avons connu
quelques autres au quotidien et puis
nous avons connu la folie des nuits
suite au décès d'Adama Traoré il y a
quelques années
jusque là nous
ions avec nos élus avec le courage de
nos élus qui était présents dans les
bâtiments municipaux alertés les
services de secours et de sécurité et
préserver les bâtiments publics vendredi
soir on l'a pas plu on n'a pas pu parce
que on a affût à faire à plus de 100
personnes
déterminées il y avait à l'évidence une
organisation il y a eu la rencontre
d'intérêts locaux avec une recherche de
prise de pouvoir par des individus que
nous connaissons et ils ont été ils ont
rencontré les intérêts
d'organisation manifestement nationale
qui sont venus prêter main fortes avec à
la fois les individus le matériel et la
stratégie donc
nous avons compris l'essentiel de ce qui
s'est passé chez nous je pense qu'il est
nécessaire que cette démarche évidemment
soit faite partout que les services de
l'État agrègent ces connaissances qu'ils
en fassent part au Parlement parce que
les parlementaires veulent savoir et
qu'on comprenne au moins les modalités
si ce n'est les raisons puisqu'il n'y
aura pas il y a pas vraiment de raison
comme la trajustement dit Françoise
Gatel mais aujourd'hui les élus locaux
sont debout comme Vincent Jean Brun le
maire de Persan la commune dont j'ai eu
l'honneur d'être le maire il est debout
avec les équipes municipales avec ses
services municipaux et la priorité c'est
de rétablir les services je ne veux pas
que l'on confonde
c'est délinquant avec la jeunesse de la
France et même avec la jeunesse de ces
quartiers ce n'est qu'une très petite
minorité mais nous avons à faire à des
bandes organisées qui cherchent à
déstabiliser notre pays c'est la
rencontre encore une fois de plusieurs
intérêts ne soyons pas naïf mais nous
pouvons compter sur les élus locaux ils
sont debout ils sont présents et
baisseront pas la tête alors on
reviendrai vers vous un peu plus tard je
voudrais qu'on va ouvrir un chapitre sur
la protection des élus parce que c'est
quand même l'une des leçons à attirer de
dans ce débat je vais vous donner
quelques chiffres l'année 2022 avait
déjà vu une forte augmentation des
agressions physiques ou verbales selon
les chiffres de l'Association des maires
de France 1720 agressions envers des
locaux c'était en 2021 plus 32% en
202265 agressions Matthieu les ces
agressions elles remettent évidemment
qui est sur la sur le devant de la scène
la question de la protection qu'est-ce
qui a changé est-ce que quelque chose a
changé sur ce pas
d'annonces mais on attend encore du
concret c'était à peine de moi vous en
souvenez la démission fracassante de
Yannick Morez le maire de Saint-Brevin
la ministre des collectivités
territoriales Dominique Faure avait
annoncé alors une batterie de mesures
pour mieux protéger les élus locaux bon
une partie de ces mesures était déjà
dans les tuyaux mais elle avait profité
de ce moment d'émotion nationale pour
pour les publier alors il y avait la
création d'un centre d'analyse et
d'action contre les violences faites aux
élus pour faire remonter les
statistiques comme si on avait déjà pas
assez ce qu'il faut sur le sujet il y
avait un réseau de 3400 référents au
sein des commissariats des gendarmeries
un renforcement du dispositif alarme élu
un peu sur le mode du téléphone grave
danger pour les femmes battues vous
savez c'est une forme de ligne directe
pour des élus en danger auprès auprès
des gendarmes plus de sensibilisation
plus de formation et puis il y avait une
mesure phare qui est l'alignement des
peines punissant les atteintes contre
les élus sur les peines punissant les
atteintes au personnel en uniformes
comme les policiers les gendarmes et les
pompiers vieilles revendications des
associations de rester une revendication
parce que pour l'instant on ne voit rien
venir est encore virtuel alors elle sera
examinée au Parlement dans les bref
délai fait savoir hier le cabinet de la
ministre lors d'un déplacement loi
Atlantique la semaine dernière soit
avant même que la maison de Vincent Jean
Brun soit prise d'assaut Dominique fort
expliquer qu'elle réfléchissait les
mesures complémentaires qui doivent être
annoncer cette semaine elle évoquait par
exemple des caméras pour protéger à la
fois les mairies mais aussi les domicile
des élus qui le souhaiteraient pour se
donner aussi des éléments la justice
afin qu'on puisse sanctionner le plus
rapidement possible quand il y a des
agressions comme celle qu'on a vu est-ce
que ça pourra pourrait suffire on le
voit bien avec le début de Séba non
évidemment dans l'immédiat peut-être je
rappelle quand vous le disiez en 2022 en
d'après le ministère de l'Intérieur les
signalements les plaintes pour violences
verbale ou physique ont des élus on on
augmente de 32% et pour ce qui est du
phénomène de fond et on a commencé à
l'aborder il faudra beaucoup plus car
au-delà de la nécessaire protection
physique des élus mais c'est le rapport
des Français à la citoyenneté le rapport
des Français d'autorité qu'il faut
réinterroger et c'est une inégalité une
inévitable fondation démocratique qui à
mon avis ne concernera pas que les
quartiers populaires mais qui interroger
le territoire tout entier Oui Chef du
ministère de l'Intérieur vous avez
raison l'Association des maires de
France j'ai j'ai pris un peu d'avance
sur un autre chiffre qu'on vous donnera
tout à l'heure
vous parliez de Dominique fort je vous
propose d'entendre un extrait de d'une
réaction de la ministre délégué au
collectivités territoriales justement
sur cette question des sanctions on
écoute quand on
s'attaque à un élu la sanction sur la
même nature que la sanction qui est
aujourd'hui
conduite auprès d'un de quelqu'un qui
s'attaque un gendarme ou un policier et
donc ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui on
n'a pas pu le passer dans la locmi
Gérald Darmanin ministre de l'intérieur
des Outre-mer n'a pas pu le faire passer
parce que sur le plan du Conseil
constitutionnel ça n'était pas possible
mais on va passer le plus vite possible
cette loi ça va permettre malgré tout de
monter jusqu'à 10 ans d'emprisonnement
quand on s'attaque à un élu et de monter
à 150000 euros d'amende donc là on était
à la mi-mai Françoise Gatel pourquoi ce
nouveau régime de sanctions pénale n'est
toujours pas entré en vigueur
alors le Sénat la beauté effectivement
dans la loi dites le pays ça n'a pas été
suivi des faits parce que le Conseil
constitutionnel a considérer cette
affaire non pas sur le fond n'a pas
contesté le fond mais a déclaré que
cette disposition n'avait rien à voir
avec le texte c'est-à-dire que c'était
un cavalier hors le président de la
commission des lois moi-même et d'autres
collègues avons déposé une proposition
de loi qui intègre cette disposition
c'est-à-dire qui permet de dire que les
élus ne sont pas au-dessus des lois il
s'agit pas de les protéger par rapport à
des dissonances de leur comportement
mais parce que amer un adjoint un
conseiller municipal quand il exerce une
fonction d'autorité il exerce au nom de
l'État dans sa commune le maire est
apprécié et qu'il doit être protégé dans
cette fonction d'autorité et que les
sanctions qui sont prononcées à
l'encontre de ceux qui agressent ces
élus doivent être comparables à celles
qui sont prononcées pour des agressions
contre des policiers
ou des ou des gendarmes et que donc
cette proposition de loi devrait venir
en débat à l'automne donc le
gouvernement peut s'inspirer si je puis
dire de ces propositions du Sénat qui
sont pas des propositions d'émotion ou
des propositions opportunistes je pense
qu'il y a des réponses
urgentes à apporter des réponses de fond
mais je crois que si on sanctionne pas
sévèrement les agressions d'élus il n'y
aura pas de signe d'alerte auprès de tas
de jeunes qui pensent que tout ça ça
peut être faire en pleine impunité que
ça n'est pas ça n'est pas un problème et
c'est pas une violence Monsieur
Mélenchon lui-même il distingue les
choses horribles que vous pourriez faire
et celles que vous ne pourriez pas faire
et à côté de ça il faut de la c'est à
dire
organiser sans doute un meilleur lien
entre la police et les élus comme on a
aujourd'hui avec la gendarmerie et puis
la réponse de fond la réponse culturelle
c'est l'éducation alors on y reviendra
évidemment sur les questions de
prévention d'éducation mais d'abord sur
ces sanctions Florent va dire est-ce que
vous pensez que ça va vraiment dissuader
ceux qui sont pas se sont attaqués ou
pourrait s'attaquer à une mairie ou un
bâtiment municipal l'avantage c'est que
depuis la loi perfide en 1980 on sait
que modifier les quantas de peine ne
change absolument rien à la délinquance
en fait ça permet éventuellement d'avoir
un accroissement d'incarcération mais ça
ne change pas le passage à l'acte donc
on peut continuer comme ça indéfiniment
à augmenter les sanctions et les
policiers demandent d'autres sanctions
plus importantes encore pour la teinte
aux personnes dépositifs de l'autorité
publique on peut aligner les régimes on
peut aller plus loin mais si vous
alimente pas un sentiment d'impunité
honnêtement je serai ravi de savoir que
les émotiers connaissent les cantats de
peine qu'ils encourent lorsqu'ils font
ça parce que piller un magasin faire de
la de ce qui s'est passé c'est à dire
c'est de la criminalité en bande
organisée c'est à dire ce sont des
quantums de peine qui peuvent aller
jusqu'à la criminalisation donc il faut
les si on était sur ces sujets là je
crois et là ce que on aurait une
capacité de d'appréhender la société de
beaucoup plus simple je pense que ça
permet de tranquilliser les les élus en
ce qu'il se sentent écoutés mais en
terme d'action judiciaire ça ne changera
rien et j'ai un même envie de dire que
ça va être encore plus compliqué de
juger ses affaires là puisque plus le
quantum est élevé plus le mode
administration de la preuve est
important et plus les décisions
judiciaires seront compliquées donc j'ai
plutôt tendance à dire que ça peut être
une bonne idée voyons dans quelques
années comment ça se traduit vers votre
avis bon il faut évidemment renforcer la
loi je suis d'accord avec vous ça ne
réglera pas le le problème moi je crois
beaucoup aux continuum c'est-à-dire je
pense que dans la mise en œuvre d'un
centre de disposition il faut que
l'injure elle est lu soit
moi même je l'ai vécu souvent les élus
se font injurier et après tout ils
aiment bien aussi être élu et donc ils
vont pas faire tout un faire tout un
comme si ça faisait partie du job comme
si ça faisait un peu partie du job et je
pense qu'il faut qu'il y ait une prise
de conscience que les élus sont invibles
c'est-à-dire y compris en termes
d'agression verbale et ça et il faut que
les élus eux-mêmes voilà je pense que
c'est il y a aussi une responsabilité
des élus que systématiquement quand il y
a agression verbale donc quand il y a le
continuum quand il y a agression verbale
cette agression verbale soit sanctionnée
et je pense que c'est comme ça que la
pédagogie pourra se faire peut-être plus
que par un renforcement de la loi qui
par ailleurs est sans doute nécessaire
mais peut-être plus par un forçant
d'abond moi je suis d'accord je crois
pas que c'est jeune beaucoup conscience
de du quantum d'hôtel auquel auquel il
se risque votre avis là-dessus à nos
voisins
sévir des des la plus petite injure
d'une certaine façon qui qui vise les
élus
qui nous manque en effet c'est des
restes ce sont des réactions précoces
nous avons mis en place à la demande de
l'état des maisons de justice et du
droit pour que les délégués lui
procureur puissent prononcer des
sanctions elles sont essentiellement
symboliques ce qui manque c'est
probablement de pouvoir faire effectuer
réellement de courtes peines de prison
qui marque
une volonté d'autorité de l'État et puis
moi je ne suis pas d'accord avec cette
idée que des peines aggraver ne serait
pas utile peut-être est-ce qu'elles ne
sont pas dissuasives on verra mais en
tout cas elles ont un énorme avantage
pour les habitants et pour les élus
c'est que pendant que les gens sont
incarcérés sont pas dans les quartiers
et les gens sont bien soulagés donc je
pense que le chantier est énorme que la
restauration de l'autorité en général
dans ce pays ça ne se va pas se faire en
trois lois et deux mois c'est évident
mais je crois que si on raisonne avec le
carcan juridique que nous avons autour
de nous aujourd'hui on arrivera à rien
donc il ne faut exister à être très
créatif pour ne pas dire avoir l'esprit
révolutionnaire en matière juridique
parce que rétablir l'autorité de l'État
aujourd'hui c'est une priorité nationale
si on veut encore être une république
demain elle est très menacée et je crois
qu'il faut rien s'interdire pour ça nous
avons le soutien des de la population
des gens les plus modestes les quartiers
populaires je
l'ai venu mais je n'avais aucun doute
là-dessus il faut avoir du courage
maintenant politique et aller jusqu'au
bout de la démarche alors un autre
chiffre qui vient lui donc de
l'Association des maires de France celui
de du nombre de mairies au bâtiments
municipaux attaqué depuis mardi 150
mairies ou bâtiments municipaux
Jean-Sébastien Ferjoux est-ce que c'est
aussi un
les symboles de la France que l'on vise
quand on s'attaque à une sur de la
République ou de la France
[Musique]
des deux et de la République et de la
France ce qui incarne l'autorité ce qui
incarne aussi peut-être l'identité et
parce qu'il y a un malaise d'identitaire
qui s'exprime aussi avec des gens qui
peut-être ne sont ni d'ici ni d'ailleurs
et qui finalement alors c'est
certainement pas une raison elle
comprenait moins bien une culture de
l'excuse mais qui sont dans une forme
peut-être de souffrance sur leur propre
identité alors ça vient de leur fait ça
vient certainement de du fait que nous
ayons pu rater l'intégration il y a des
travaux très intéressants qui ont été
menés par France stratégie qui montre
justement le degré d'isolement des
populations immigrées ou des descendants
d'immigrés en réalité qui vivent
vraiment il y a des ghettos en France
bien plus que ce qu'on imagine et autant
vous pouvez vous intégrer je sais pas si
vous êtes admettons 10 20% par rapport à
80% de français autant quand vous êtes
dans un quartier ou de toute façon 80%,
85% de la population présente et
elle-même d'origine étrangère avec des
codes culturels des valeurs différents
mais à quoi vous vous intégrez vous vous
intégrez à vous avez parmi vos voisins
mais ce que je trouve étonnant c'est de
vouloir saucissonner les problèmes en
fait alors oui on peut toujours alourdir
la loi les sanctions contre les élus
contre les policiers contre les pompiers
contre mais on saucissonne les problèmes
mais le sujet on voit bien que c'est le
défaut d'autorité dans le pays c'est
parce qu'on a déconstruit l'autorité et
ça répond aussi à la question que vous
posez qu'est-ce qu'on attaque dans ces
symboles là pourquoi c'est la police
aussi qui a beaucoup attaqué ce qui a
plus personne qui ose dire non
aujourd'hui il y a des enfants plus
personne n'ose dire non il y a plus les
parents il y a plus structures
associatives il y a plus dans les
quartiers en question les grands frères
qui étaient une institution d'ailleurs
qui peut faire une institution mais une
organisation un mode d'organisation
sociale qui a pu être contestée il y a
plus vraiment la parole religieuse on a
entendu des appels au calme d'un certain
nombre d'imam vendredi dernier ça pas eu
l'air de beaucoup fonctionner et donc
les seuls qui incarnent encore encore
quelque chose qui dit non à la
toute-puissance en fait parce qu'il y a
quelque chose de sa dimension là c'est
c'est à dire que oui il y a la dimension
dessérés et il y a la dimension
politique les deux ne s'opposent pas
parce que je voulais revenir quand même
sur a été dit tout à l'heure je pense
que dire que ça n'a aucun sens pour le
coup moi ça me paraît d'avoir aucun sens
dans les révolutions dans les émeutes
les émeutes ça a toujours existé Patrick
ganifet a travaillé par exemple sur les
déferlements de violences de la
Révolution française les faits il existe
il a existé dans les colonnes infernales
en Vendée comme il a existé à d'autres
endroits dans les émeutes comme ça
existait dans les jacquies j'en ai rien
inventé aujourd'hui la nature humaine
elle reste la nature humaine dire que
c'est juste des gens qui seraient
particulièrement dessérés ça n'a pas de
sens ça s'inscrit dans un contexte
politique avec oui des gens qui ont des
codes qui sont désormais différents et
qui en plus ne sont plus dans une
culture de l'écrit mais dans une culture
de l'image et de l'émotion et ça nous
fait réagir et je redonne la parole à
Françoise Gatel justement à faire un
mouvement qui soit polymorphe on a quand
même dans ce mouvement une forme de
délinquance d'opportunités constatée ou
non chez certains jeunes qui vont piller
des magasins parce que la portée est
ouverte parce que la vitrine a été
fracassée par un autre on a des symboles
forts qui ont été pris pour cible c'est
vrai les commissariats les écoles mais
tu vas en public puis les mairies et
puis on a dans l'affaire Vincent Jean
Brun quelque chose qui ressemble quand
même une forme d'expédition punitive on
est dans un autre schéma à mon avis que
la délinquance opportunité je vais voler
un polo de marque dans dans la vitrine
ouverte parce que il faut avoir
l'adresse de du maire il faut s'armer il
faut y aller aux écussons je suis pas là
de l'organisation on est quand même sur
autre chose mais enfin ça c'est aussi la
nouvelle dimension aux réseaux sociaux
ou on voit quand même pas mal dans
l'effet de mode dont vous parliez je
connais ton adresse je la diffuse voir
le numéro de téléphone après il faut
s'organiser
de 12-13 ans qui vont voler des t-shirts
et aussi il héberge en son sein et
malheureusement les gens qui sont
capables d'expédition punitive mais moi
la question qui que je me pose c'est
comment on est quand même passé de la
haine du flic entre guillemets à la
haine du maire c'est quand même pas le
même registre et même si on sait que le
maire on l'a dit et le représentant de
l'autorité dans sa ville tout part quand
même d'une demande de ice ou de
dénonciation de violences policières
avec le meurtre de Naël pourquoi on s'en
prend en mer aujourd'hui à Françoise
Gatel un mot quand même parce que
Jean-Sébastien Ferjou était pas d'accord
avec vous sur la question de voilà de de
desserrer donc je vais entendre votre
réponse là-dessus
on a bien compris
effectivement les causes sont
polymorment mais quand je dis que ça n'a
pas de sens et ça n'obéit à aucun
raisonnement logique ou républicain
c'est cela que je veux dire puis je veux
dire je suis en parfait des accords avec
Monsieur vanillo moi je viens qu'on dise
que rien ne réglera rien dans ce cas-là
on continue à allumer des bougies à
sortir les drapeaux à chanter la
Marseillaise et que la sanction que nous
on propose c'est pas du Prozac pour les
élus pour leur dire on s'occupe de vous
vous verrez il y aura une vraie punition
moi je pense que la punition à un moment
elle est exemplaire parce qu'elle porte
au niveau de tout un groupe de jeunes on
l'a vu dans nos communes quand on fait
faire à des jeunes des travaux d'intérêt
général ça c'est c'est un autre rapport
à la collectivité et je l'ai dit moi je
pense que la sanction c'est pas la
réponse à tout il faut prévenir il faut
éduquer et on dit très souvent qu'il
faut un village pour éduquer les enfants
et Badinter la redit l'autre jour si on
a une
des difficultés familiales à un déficit
d'éducation silicone n'arrive plus à
gérer tout ça si la police est conçue
comme un ennemi c'est si le policier les
plus dans la rue au milieu des gens on a
plus rien en partage et tout ce qui ne
me sert pas peut être agressé c'est
aussi tout ça qu'il y a derrière
Florent va dire autre réponse non mais
je veux sortir de la caricature je ne
dis pas qu'il faut rien faire et brûler
des sièges mais je vous signale madame
la sénatrice vous êtes législateur donc
les travaux d'intérêt général ils
peuvent être prononcés à titre principal
ou titre de peine accessoires en
l'espèce si vous augmentez les cantats
de peine les travaux d'intérêt général
ne seront pas prononçables donc il y a
pas de sujet là dessus mais il faut être
cohérent sur l'échelle des délices et
des peines et enfin et c'est ce que
disait aussi Arnaud basin moi je veux
bien qu'on parle de politique pénale
mais il y a quand même une boîte noire
dont on ne parle jamais c'est la prison
parce que quand on entend dire qu'il
faut des courtes peines de prison c'est
ce que on a théorisé comme le choc
carcéral ça ne marche pas les taux de
récidive de choc carcéral on peut
revenir sur la politique des Pays-Bas
mais le taux de récif du choc carcéral
en France c'est près de 60% en prison
[Musique]
je dis juste que quand on réfléchit
uniquement en termes d'incrimination
pénale et que derrière on ne crée pas de
parcours pénal on ne crée pas de moyens
de travail de réinsertion on ne
diversifie pas les modes d'incarcération
on ne régle rien donc on peut pas
uniquement bouger le bouton de la clim
sans savoir s'il y a derrière un
climatiseur
Arnaud Bazin votre réponse sur la
réponse sécurité mais vous l'avez dit un
peu tout à l'heure la réponse sécurise
terre il la faute elle est pas
suffisante
alors est-ce qu'on entend Arnaud Bazin
j'ai l'impression qu'on l'a perdu alors
Jean-Sébastien faire je voulais
intervenir allez-y oui je suis au delà
du débat sur la hauteur de la réponse
pénale parce qu'encore faut-il que les
magistrats appliquent d'ailleurs les
lois on peut toujours augmenter les
quantums de peine encore faut-il les
appliquer oui mais après quand on
regarde les nominations qui sont
concrètement 7 au sommet de la
hiérarchie judiciaire et le en même
temps produit cet effet là aussi c'est
qu'on peut avoir des déclarations
martiales du ministre de l'intérieur
mais dénominations de magistrats
particulièrement engagés dans une vision
finalement proche de celle qui a été
celle de Christiane Taubira madame
beloubès était exactement la même qui
était la première garde des sceaux
d'Emmanuel Macron c'était exactement la
même vision que Madame tobira mais je
voulais en venir à la réprobation parce
que mine de rien ça n'est pas la même
chose d'avoir une peine qu'en plus quand
vous rentrez chez vous votre famille vos
proches votre entourage et expriment une
réprobation que d'encourir une peine que
déjà elle intervienne très longtemps
après parce que la justice est lente que
ça soit du sursis ou des travaux
d'intérêts généraux qui ne sont jamais
véritablement effectués parce que encore
faut-il avoir les moyen de les encadrer
et pas de réprobation parce que si on
considère qu'il y a des gens qui peuvent
être enfin que ce sont des petits anges
pour reprendre l'expression employés par
Kylian Mbappé moi je comprends
absolument l'émotion liée à la mort de
Naël ça n'est pas la même chose que de
dire qu'il y a des gens qui sont par
ailleurs délinquants quand même enfin
conduire sans permis c'est être
délinquant qu'on lui dire enfin mettre
des gens en danger c'est être délinquant
et il y a pas de réprobation parce qu'on
a emporté une vision américaine on
importe une vision américaine du racisme
systémique ce qui explique peut-être
d'ailleurs le fait qu'on soit passé de
la haine de la police à la haine des
élus aussi parce qu'il y a quand même
cette dimension là on en parle peu en
France parce que la culture républicaine
fait qu'on en parle peu mais enfin il
suffit de ouvrir de regarder une chaîne
américaine pour voir comment il
décrivent la situation c'est un arabe
tué par un policier blanc et c'est bien
comme ça que l'on vécu aussi les
habitants ou un certain nombre
d'habitants en tout cas des quartiers on
ne peut pas évacuer cette dimension là
mais le problème c'est que comme on est
dans la culpabilité et que finalement il
y a toute une partie du discours
politique qui entretient cette idée des
violences économique des violences
policières du racisme institutionnel qui
aurait en France dans le même temps moi
je constate que il y a jamais eu autant
de réfugiés en France plus de 500 000
pour que viennent-ils faire dans cet
enfer raciste mais islamophobe alors
quand vous dites ça vous pensez
évidemment entre autres agents Luc
Mélenchon on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure
on va écouter un extrait de cette
déclaration c'était vendredi soir
effectivement
bon il fait une sorte de de liste de ce
qu'il faut sauvegarder écoutons-le non
l'école et le temple le plus sacré que
tu es garçon ou fille faut pas y toucher
la bibliothèque le gymnase tout ce qui
est à nous tous qui est notre bien
commun
Françoise Gatel comment vous avez réagi
en entendant cette déclaration de du
leader de la France insoumise
je
suis irritée
je trouve ça indécent parce que Monsieur
Mélenchon arrive avec son air solennel
comme Dieu sur terre et en gros il
explique mon garçon alors ce qui est à
nous tu n'y touches pas le reste on ne
sait pas mais en gros tu peux te lâcher
sur le reste mais je pense que ce
personnage
participe de l'impulsion
que l'on voit se développer dans le pays
à s'affranchir de tout et à commettre
des actes qui non seulement sont
illicites mais sont d'une violence
extrêmement grave c'est à dire Monsieur
Mélenchon s'arroche le droit de dire
quelle destruction est bonne et
qu'est-ce qui n'est pas bon mais est-ce
qu'on se rencontre de la conversation
que nous sommes en train d'avoir et de
ce que Monsieur Mélenchon qui a l'air
d'assis sur un trot vous assène comme
vérité c'est pure folie je trouve le
propos criminel
votre avis je partage cet avis j'étais
moi aussi très choqué par cette
intervention à choqué parce
qu'évidemment en creux ça dit vous
pouvez aller brûler le reste mais moi
j'aimerais qu'on dise aussi et qu'on se
penche aussi pour l'ensemble de la
société sur les problèmes qui sont posés
et qui à mon avis ne seront pas
fondamentalement réglés par des une
logique sécurité j'aimerais poser le
problème de l'horizon et de l'avenir ce
sont des gamins qui ne sentent pas avoir
un avenir bon ça n'excuse rien c'est pas
d'excuse c'est simplement une
constatation moi j'ai développé ça dans
le grand mal des temps du climatique en
disant qu'on ne voyait pas l'horizon on
ne voyait pas sur ce sujet mais pour
plusieurs sujets sociaux et sociétaux on
ne voit pas l'horizon on ne voit pas où
on va où va la France et de ce point de
vue là il y a vraiment je pense un
problème et le deuxième souci majeur je
pense c'est la culture de la
responsabilité individuelle et
collective et pas simplement individuel
individuel et collective c'est à dire
concrètement des gamins dans un quartier
ou en effet c'est
avec une famille monoparentale pas
économique parce que ce ne sont pas des
gâteaux
dans laquelle ils ont il y a une seule
il y a leur mère simplement le père a
disparu dans lequel ils ont quand même
beaucoup de mal à ne pas se sentir
discriminé quoi qu'on en dise bon et
donc je pense et tout ça renvoie à quoi
ça renvoie pour le cas particulier des
quartiers mais on pourrait l'appliquer à
l'ensemble de la société ça envoie un
problème de responsabilité collective
c'est-à-dire de se dire que nous sommes
collectivement responsables d'un certain
nombre de choses de notre pays et à
partir du moment où il y a pas cette
culture là et vous cette culture
disparaît qui revient d'ailleurs à ce
que l'intégration de se fait pas et moi
je suis je trouve très dommage que le
débat ça ne justifie rien je mais que le
débat sur l'intégration soit aussi mal
posé il y a évidemment un débat sur
l'intégration ça fait 20 ans que c'est
2005 parce qu'il est visiblement
alors il est il est peut-être il est
possible d'avoir un débat serein sur
cette question moi je pense
que c'est la pression
avec les éléments les émeutes pardon du
Black live matter personne ne disait ici
c'est chez nous on n'est pas américain
vous nous il y avait une dénonciation
d'un racisme qui pour le coup c'est
construit très différemment dans la
société américaine que ce que la manière
dont il y a du racisme en France ça
n'est pas structuré ça n'est pas
l'histoire du pays qui s'est construite
là-dessus mais on voit bien que c'est la
France qui pose problème et c'est
effectivement il y a une part de
responsabilité collective parce qu'on a
eu aussi un antiracisme vraiment dévoyé
qui a fini par invisibiliser les gens en
question parce que quand vous êtes en
permanence dans la culture de l'excuse
quand vous dites ça n'est que nous qui
sommes méchants parce que on est des
méchants blancs le c'est le patriarcat
c'est le capitaliste et je sais pas quoi
vous nier la responsabilité de l'autre
mais c'est comme si vous nier son
existence même le fait par exemple de ne
pas sanctionner quelqu'un c'est une
forme d'invisibilité et c'est une forme
de violence
j'aimerais bien que on fasse le point
sur les 30 années qui viennent de sortir
pour voir quel projet ont été réalisés
avec quelle somme ligne par ligne parce
que la réalité elle est là on a arrosé
le désert avec de l'argent qui n'a
jamais profité aux populations
concernées allez on termine là-dessus
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
premier débat ici en plateau et
évidemment également en duplex je vous
dis à bientôt sur sur public